we launched a spacecraft 7 years ago
from Earth a moving platform towards the
asteroid benu a moving Target we arrive
there it does a touch and go grabbing
material on that touch it packs it into
a capsule that space probe continues
intersects Earth deploys the capsule
such that on the rotating Earth it lands
within a Zone in the Utah desert and
that space craft continues on to another
asteroid and that's what it is
programmed to do it's behaving as we
intended for it's called science as a
matter of fact it is rocket science we
did this we pulled this off yet there
are people walking Among Us say I don't
believe science I don't trust science do
you see what it is we do do you have any
understanding of what this takes